Salam alaikum guys we're in survival and
this is called
bhashya well more further this is that
we're like here in downtown Center okay
this is a little bit more over there so
we're standing behind a Catholic Church
a Catholic Church one interesting thing
is that is this true that during the war
this is the greatest genocide that had
happened after World War two here and
pretty much we don't blame Christianity
even though it was a crusade against
Muslims but we don't blame Christianity
even though it was hijacked at that time
but just an interesting point but
another even more interesting point is
that Muslims executing the teachings of
Islam and Prophet Muhammad's orders you
will not have seen if they weren't
following Islam Islam preserved this
church is that right that's right
like in Sarajevo I don't know the number
of the churches so how many churches are
in Sarajevo but not a single one during
the three and a half years occupation of
Sarajevo was destroyed this is the main
church of Sarajevo it's in downtown like
the straight downtown area the only
thing that that it wasn't destroyed but
the grenades from the from the Serbian
side that dropped thousands over five
hundred thousand grenades out during the
two and a half years and the only damage
it it got the churches from those
grenades so not a single church was
destroyed or anything but by the Muslim
side by the Bosnians so before the
Geneva Convention code there was the
mercy that the Creator sent through the
mercy to mankind Prophet Muhammad peace
and blessings be upon him who said don't
kill in the innocent non-combatants now
when you're fighting in combat you know
we're gonna send a guy you know a love
letter and know you're in combat against
an enemy self-defense but we're talking
about now the places of worship there
are off limits
so unlike others who are just destroying
demolishing my
and houses a worship Islam forbids that
and that's why this is we're able to
stand in front of a church right here
and witness that and we just heard the
Bell right yeah also it's been all the
time during the war the Bell was here
and like I said not a single church was
destroyed or damaged by the Bosnians by
the Muslims during the war
there's also 50 meters down there
there's a Serbian Orthodox Church the
Serbs occupied the town it was occupied
for two and a half years and the church
in downtown Sarajevo wasn't touched by
the Muslims by the Bosnians because the
church didn't care occupy the the the
city the the military the army the
Serbian army did so this is an another
example of Islam being a mercy for
mankind and for the Croatians and
Serbians this is your uniting factor
that Islam is able to bring all of these
nationalities together under the worship
because you have Serbians Croatians and
Bosnians that can actually they're their
Muslim worshiping one God beyond all the
nationalism yeah nationalism it's not
important Islam doesn't recognize
nationalism Islam doesn't teach
nationalism Islam is some submission to
God and that's what makes you a Muslim
when you submit to God no matter what
nationality you are Muslim Bosnian
Serbian Croatian German European
American no matter you learn something
here beyond all the hype continue to
tune in we're here in Bosnia bringing
some fast now fiction we'll see you next
time peace be with you soon on Lakers
motto motto I'm so much she got a
creation in a Bosnian together and
that's how we should be working together
as human beings right dump all the
nationalism because there's only one
creator one guy